here's the top three reasons to download
the Google app right away a huge thank
you to Google for partnering with me on
this video number one you can translate
text using a photo you can use a photo
that you've already taken or you can use
Google Lens to translate it live this is
so incredible using Google Lens I live
translated a portion of my book number
two you can identify plants or flowers a
friend recently gave me this cute plant
and I just want to confirm it is what I
think it is look at that aloe vera lens
identifies it immediately number three
you can actually shop with Google Lens
you can actually scan it to scan the
barcode or just take a picture of an
image and it'll find something similar
and there it is all of the places that
you can buy my book and that my friends
are my top three favorite things about
the new Google app